dr. nicholas christakis directs the
human nature lab and is the code
of the Institute for network science
he's a social scientist and physician
who conducts research on social factors
that affect health healthcare and
longevity his current research focuses
on health and social networks and
especially with how ill health
disability health behavior health care
and death in one person can influence
the same phenomena in others in a
person's social network this work
involves the application of network
science and mathematical models to
understand the dynamics of it all please
welcome dr. Nicholas Christakis with why
humans have friends so I think so thank
you very much for that introduction so
what I'm going to be speaking about
today in the 20 minutes or so that I
have is real human social networks and
not so much the online variety but
rather the kind we humans have been
making and embedding ourselves in for
tens of thousands of years and the
structure and function of human social
networks are we think deeply rooted in
our biology and in our evolutionary past
and I also want to make a few remarks
about what we might do with this
knowledge so what if we understand the
structure and function of human social
networks what's the point of a basic
science program that seeks to understand
how and why we assemble ourselves into
these networks what can we do with this
knowledge to make a world a better place
I'm going to be telling you about a
couple of experiments that we've been
doing in our group to explore how we
might intervene in human social networks
in order to make the world better
improving Public Health fostering
cooperation and increasing other
desirable properties of human
populations so on so here is what so
here's what a real social network looks
like every dot is a person every line
connecting them is a relationship
between the two people and each of us
chooses our friends and our co-workers
and inherit in our spouses and inherits
our relatives and each of those people
to whom we are in
connected also has other such
individuals and in the process of each
of us exercising these choices we
assemble ourselves into this incredibly
ornate structure and we proceed to live
out our lives embedded in this structure
and to me social networks are intricate
things of beauty and they are so
elaborate and so complex and so
ubiquitous in fact that one has to
wonder what purpose do they serve I mean
why do we do this we humans this is the
equivalent of ant colonies we assemble
these elaborate structures we live our
lives within these structures and they
have this particular kind of appearance
as I'm going to show you so the
questions become how to networks form
how do they work and how do they affect
us and I spent the last 10 years or so
researching how and why human beings
form social networks and how they affect
our lives how they affect our health our
desires our feelings our thoughts and
our actions and briefly start with the
work that we did with obesity because it
sets the stage for illustrating a number
of other points so now as most of you
probably know the prevalence of obesity
has been increasing dramatically over
the last 10 years in our society going
from about twenty percent of Americans
being obese to thirty percent of
Americans being obese and it's common to
speak about obesity as being epidemic
and it's clear that obesity epidemic in
one meaning of the word which is that
there's more of it than there used to be
before but we wondered whether we could
find evidence evidence for obesity being
epidemic and another meaning of the word
meaning that there's some kind of
contagion between individuals could we
find evidence for a spreading process of
weight gain within human populations and
to the extent that obesity is a product
of personal choices and voluntary
behaviors and the fact given the fact
that people are embedded in these social
networks and are influenced by the
behaviors of others around them we
thought it should be possible to find
evidence for obesity epidemics and this
image taken from one of our first
studies helped us to understand the role
of social networks in obesity every dot
is a person every line between them
represents a relationship between two
people and we make the dot size
proportional to people's body mass index
so bigger dots are bigger people and in
addition we colored the dots yellow if
they're properly obese and if you look
at this image you might be able to see
clusters of yellow and red dots within
the system as if there were little
outbreaks of obese
the little sort of epidemics many
epidemics within this this social
network but still the complexity is very
high visually speaking and in any case
several questions are raised by this
clustering such as how much clustering
is there is there more clustering than
due to chance how big are the clusters
and most interestingly what might cause
the clusters so we borrowed some ideas
from statistical physics and we analyzed
the data in the following fashion on the
y-axis is the increase in the
probability that a person is obese given
that a social contact of theirs is obese
and on the x-axis is the degrees of
separation between the two people and
what this says on the far left purple
bar but if your friends are obese you've
got a forty five percent higher
likelihood of being obese yourself and
in the red bar if your friends friends
are obese you've got a twenty-five
percent higher likelihood of being obese
and in the orange bar if your three
degrees of separation if your friends
friends friends are obese you've got a
ten percent higher likelihood of being
obese and it's only when i get to your
friends friends friends friends at four
degrees of separation that there's no
longer a relationship between that
person's body size and your body size so
this kind of mathematical analysis
confirms a couple of things first
there's more clustering than due to
chance if they were chance assortment of
obese and non-obese individuals within
the social network the lines here would
be zero percent across the board and
second that the radius of the clusters
is 23 degrees of separation so if I knew
nothing else about you then the body
size of this person who's almost
certainly a stranger to you your friends
friends friend for example I would be
better than chance able to predict your
body size but this analysis doesn't tell
us what might be the cause of these
clusters and there at least three
possibilities one possibility is a kind
of social domino effect I gain weight it
makes Tom gain weight Tom gain way to
get sandy gain weight and there's a kind
of spreading process through the network
a kind of induction effect a second
possibility is homophony our love of
like or birds of a feather flock
together maybe it's not that my weight
gain causes Tom's weight gain maybe he
and I form a relationship because we
have a similar body size to begin with
and a third possibility is that it's
neither that my weight is causing his
way nor that we form a relationship
because we have a similar body size but
rather that there is something in the
context maybe a nearby gym that makes us
both lose weight or a nearby fast-food
joint that makes us both
wait at the same time all three of these
processes are typically present in any
social phenomenon and the challenge is
to use correct econometrics methods to
dis articulate the statistical methods
to see evidence for each of those three
or to do experiments as I'll show you in
a moment and so and these typically
occur in anything are your kids doing
drugs because their friends are doing
drugs or are they already drug doing
kids that are choosing other drug doing
kids or is there a local pusher that's
pushing drugs on all the kids these
types of ideas can be examined with all
kinds of phenomena and so we did a
variety of observational and
experimental approaches to sort this out
and we found evidence for induction in
the social networks we found evidence
for spread of obesity a kind of social
contagion within the system and in the
process we also documented himali and
the role of context in a variety of ways
now we also became interested in other
sorts of phenomena for example we became
interested in human emotions when human
beings have emotions like anger or
happiness or fear or disgust we show
them why why do we do that it's not hard
to construct an argument from
evolutionary biology as to why we would
experience emotions why it would
increase our fitness to be able to
experience these things but not like do
I experience these things but I show
them and not only do I show them but you
can read them and not only do you read
them but you copy them it would seem
that emotional contagion is a very deep
and fundamental aspect of human
emotional experience and in fact this
function of emotions suggest that
whatever other advantages they offer
emotions are also a primitive form of
communication now we're accustomed to
thinking about emotional contagion as
fleeting and involving a pair of people
for example a few years ago I talked
about this work in New York City and I
said you know when you're on the subway
and the person across the car from you
smiles at you and you instinctively
smile back and they said we don't do
that in New York City
and I said well everywhere else in the
world that's normal human behavior and
in fact Jane Goodall when she looks at
when she studied chimpanzee she saw the
chimps when one shows a play face which
is the precursor of our smiling another
chimp will show the play face there's
something very primitive in ancient
about emotional contagion and we also
realize that emotional contagion can be
broader still for example in the
punctuated and broad expressions of
anger but we wondered whether emotions
might spread beyond pairs of people and
might they do so in a more sustained way
than riots could there be a kind of a
quiet riot could there be a kind of
below the surface emotional stampede
could we borrow the mathematics that's
used to study this type of flocking
behavior in birds and in fishes and use
it an applied to humans and see whether
humans synchronously move when it comes
to emotions or other behaviors and could
we find evidence that emotions spread
across network ties well beyond pairs in
a more sustained fashion all the time
maybe in fact emotions have a collective
existence and not just an individual
existence and so we made one of the
first network maps I think the first
network map of human emotions within I
support every dot is a person lines
represent relationships the blue dots
are sad people and the yellow dots are
happy people and the green dots are in
between and if you look at this image
you can once again see clusters of sad
and happy people within the social
fabric it to goes to three degrees of
separation and similar analyses to those
that we did for obesity suggest that
there's a role of induction emotional
contagion and also of himali and
contextual effects you might also note
that there's a structural thing because
the blue dots are more likely to be on
the edges of the network they're more
likely to be structurally on the
periphery of the social fabric now to
get around some of the problems with
drawing conclusions from observational
data and to dig deeper into the
evolutionary significance of networks
we've also begun to do experiments so
one of the experiments we did is we
brought people into the laboratory we
gave with strangers we randomly assign
them to groups of four and we gave them
a little bit of money and we said if
you're kind and give the money to your
colleagues these other strangers we will
multiply that money and everyone will be
better off even though you've paid a
price so the logical thing for any
individual to do is to do
fact not to be kind hope everyone else
is kind and they'll benefit but of
course if everyone does that the whole
group suffers so it's a trade-off
between individual benefit and
collective benefit and then we would
ring the bell and we would randomly
assign them new strangers and then ring
a bell and randomly assign them new
strangers and we did this for multiple
rounds and what we found was that if
eleni is kind to Lucas in period one
Lucas goes on to be kind into Erica in
period two and Erica goes on to be kind
to Jay in period 3 and Jay goes on to be
kind to Brecon in period for this shows
a spread a kind of pay it forward of
altruism and kindness this is not if I'm
kind to you do you reciprocate the
kindness this is if I'm kind to you do
you are you than kind to her and is she
then kind to her and one of this this
result was one of the most bizarre
results out of my lab in the last five
years because what I've just shown you
is that whether Jay treats brecon kindly
depends on howell any treats Lucas even
though neither Jane or brecon ever saw
eleni or Lucas how I treat you depends
on how she treats her even though we
don't know those two people because the
effects spread through the system like a
kind of social contagion so pay it
forward is real and in fact when all the
ripples are added together it's clear
that the network functions as a kind of
matching grant doubling the return on
the first person's initial contribution
to the public good and hence using both
observational and experimental methods
we and others have provided evidence
that a variety of behaviors and
phenomena spread within networks via
social contagion we've looked at obesity
smoking drinking and drug use emotional
states happiness loneliness depression I
showed you some altruism sleep exercise
purchasing behavior and ideas and the
network structure the actual
mathematical structure of these networks
is highly relevant to other sorts of
phenomena such as the spread of germs
and the spread of information
understanding the pattern of human
interactions gives us new techniques to
intervene and epidemics to stop them
cold or to forecast them in ways that
alas I don't have time to discuss today
networks also facilitate a kind of
learning social learning that involves
learning from others rather than from
one's own experience and in fact one of
the key ideas that we've been converging
on is that networks magnify whatever
they are
seated with one of the reasons we have
friends is to create a social magnifying
glass this social magnifying glass
magnifies anything it is seated with it
will magnify fascism it will magnify
Ebola it will magnify violence it will
also magnify altruism and happiness and
information it is agnostic it will
magnify anything but it must be seated
you must put something into it but then
we humans by assembling ourselves into
these networks take over or kick it off
and make it much bigger now this work
with emotions and with cooperation which
are so fundamental has gotten and
coupled with the idea that networks may
have a function got us to thinking about
the evolutionary basis of networks
themselves and human social networks
always look strikingly similar they
always look like the images that I've
been showing you so far but they never
look like this they never look like a
regular lattice why not I mean why
didn't we evolve to be an animal that
makes networks that naturally look like
this well the striking patterns of human
social networks their ubiquity and their
apparent purpose beg the question of
whether we evolve to have them and to
particular kind of networks in the first
place so humans are very unusual as a
species in that we form stable long-term
non-reproductive unions to other members
of our species namely we have friends
why why do we have friends it's not hard
to construct an argument from
evolutionary biology as to why we would
have sex with other people it's rather
more difficult to explain why we
befriend other people and yet we and
very few other species engage in this
very unusual behavior so to understand
this we need to understand ette work
structure a little bit first first of
all notice that in this type of a
network every position is the same as
every other position everyone has eight
friends and every one of their friends
has eight friends and if I took this
surface and wrapped it around a sphere
or more properly a donut every position
would be equally central and peripheral
in the network but of course that's not
what natural networks look like natural
networks have this kind of a structure
and I want to very briefly introduce
three concepts from network science and
then make a couple of points about
evolutionary biology and talk briefly
about introductions and I think I will
be able to finish on time so
so look at node b b has if i keep
speaking at this velocity ah so node
node b has 4 friends and no d has six
friends okay beyond the upper left and d
on the far right this is known as the
degree of a node and people know this
about themselves you know you have five
friends you know you have four friends I
have no friends people know how many
friends they have now look at nodes C
and D see in the middle d on the right
they both have six friends and this
might be the limit of their
understanding of where they are in the
network but we with this bird's eye view
can see that C and D are very different
and I can cultivate this intuition and
you by asking you who would you rather
be if a deadly germ was spreading
through the network C or D D you want to
be on the edge you want to be so that
you're not going to get whatever
spreading now who would you rather be if
a juicy piece of gossip we're spreading
through the network see right that's
known as the centrality of a node now
nodes a and B both have four friends the
difference between them however is that
A's friends are friends with each other
and B's friends are not so an ace friend
is known as transitivity my friends
friend is my friend in a my friends
friend is not my friend in B and all
three of these traits it turns out are
heritable so in some other work we
published also with an eye support on
the far right the percent of variance
explained to the heritability is shown
and forty-six percent of the variation
and how many friends people have can be
explained by their genes now that's not
a shocker but some of us are born shy
some of us are born gregarious that
people vary in their taste for
friendship is not big news but we also
find that forty-seven percent in the
variation in people's transitivity can
also be explained by your genes this is
another very bizarre result out of my
lab the last few years what I've just
told you is that if you have Tom Dick
and Harry in a room where their dick is
friends with Harry depends not just on
dicks genes or on Harry's genes but on
Tom's genes where their dick is friends
with Harry depends on the genes of some
other person how can that be we think
the reason is that people vary in their
tendency to introduce their friends to
each other some knit the networks around
them together and some do not and even
centrality is also partially heritable
so where you are in this vast fabric of
humanity depends in part on your jeans
and the fundamental reality of our
desire for particular kinds of
connection has always been with us
now if social network structure has
biological and genetic antecedents and
evolutionary significance it begs the
question of how ancient this structure
is and whether we can document it in non
modernized settings so what we would
love to do is fly 10,000 years back to
the Pleistocene and map those networks
and the claim should be they should be
the same as ours and we can't do that
but the next best thing we could do was
to go and study the Hansa who are one of
the last remaining hunter-gatherer
populations on the planet they live like
we did 10,000 years ago they have no
material possessions to speak of they
sleep out under the stars they don't
have agriculture and so forth and so we
studied 17 hodzic camps around like
Agassi and Tanzania we took made of odds
of Facebook we made a photographic
census of all the adult haja there only
a thousand of them left only 500 of them
live in the traditional way we took this
haads of Facebook into the field we
asked the Hansa to identify their
friends in a variety of ways and to make
the long story short odds of social
networks look just like ours visually
and mathematically and everything we
could throw at them despite the fact
that in the intervening 10,000 years
we've invented agriculture and cities
and telecommunications we make the same
networks that they do so network
structure has an ancient origin and it
doesn't seem to have changed and we've
begun to think about and then I want to
present these two experiments and then
I'll stop we've begun to think about how
to exploit these observed properties of
networks and other fundamental
observations about network structure in
order to intervene in social systems to
maximize behavior change by exploiting a
mathematical understanding of human
interactions and of the rules
undergirding social contagion and we
have two kinds of ideas one is that we
can manipulate connections between
people changing the structure of the
network or we can manipulate contagion
and change the flows manipulate how
things flow through the system and
there's expanding science in both areas
one experiment and I'm just going to
show you experiments with respect to
social contagion here's a recent
experiment of ours manipulating
contagion we I decided we were going to
map networks in developing world
villages imagine the village on the left
and the village of the right every dot
is a person and the lines represent
social relationships in the village on
the right we're going to pick six people
at random
we're going to give them an intervention
like a clean water intervention or a
vaccine intervention or an anti-malarial
bed net intervention and in the village
on the left in the control village we're
going to give no one an intervention now
the conventional way of thinking about
interventions of Public Health is to
come back and look at the people you
treated and see whether they responded
I'm not interested in the people that I
treated I'm interested in the people I
didn't treat how did the intervention
spread by contagion from the treated to
the untreated in the treatment village
on the right compared to the control
village on the left so maybe three of
the six people responded on the right
and they recruited three of their
friends so six of them responded overall
and on the left in the control village
maybe two people responded after all
what if instead however picking people
at random I pick six central people or
use some other mathematical insights to
pick who's influential who's in a
structural position of power in the
network same villages same intervention
same number of people targeted much
bigger effect potentially now maybe
three of the six respond but they
recruit 30 of their friends so I get 33
respondents for the same amount of money
spent and the same kind of intervention
and we can experiment with different
algorithms different ways of picking
these individuals so we begun to do this
in different locations around the world
i'm going to show you one study that
we're doing in the highland villages of
honduras this is what the area looks
like we mapped the social networks of 32
villages spread out in space in this
region we randomly assigned the villages
to different targeting algorithms a
third of the villages that people were
five percent of the people were picked
at random a third five percent of the
most central people were picked and a
third five percent were picked by the
Christakis lab secret sauce in a very
special way and and the question is
could we move the whole village can we
make the whole village do what we want
the same ideas can be applied in
classrooms in the inner city in nursing
homes in hospitals to get doctors to
prescribe or change their behavior very
same ideas can be applied broadly and
what we found was that we could do that
on the y-axis is the mean proportion of
expressing this this is a multivitamin
intervention and on the x-axis is time
and what we found is at the beginning
five percent of the people had the
intervention by the end nearly eighty
percent did and it was the best when we
use the strategy
in the purple strategy and we have many
other similar results so I'm going to
stop with these two slides think about
these two objects they are both made of
carbon and as we all learned in high
school chemistry the difference between
these two objects is how the carbon
atoms are connected take the carbon
atoms and connect them one way you get
graphite which is soft and dark connect
them another way you get diamond which
is hard and clear and there are two key
intellectual ideas here first these
properties of softness and darkness and
hardness and clearness aren't properties
of the carbon atoms there are properties
of the collection of carbon atoms second
which properties you get depends on how
you connect the carbon atoms to each
other connect them one way you get one
set of properties connect them a
different way you get a different set of
properties similarly the pattern of our
connections among human beings affects
the properties of social groups it is
the ties between people that make the
whole greater than the sum of its parts
and new properties maybe even
cooperation or infection resistance or
intelligence may emerge because of the
connections because of the ties between
people and not necessarily because of
the people themselves in fact our
experience of the world depends on the
actual structure of the ties around us
near and far thank you very much
you